my name is vincent i work as a research
advocate at braza
essentially my job uh by and large is to
make sure that whatever
our lovely team of researchers come up
with that that's relatively well
understood for
our developers and that we you know
contribute a little bit of knowledge in
the whole nlp
realm so there's this new technology you
might have heard of it's called
transformer
and the goal of this talk is to give a
somewhat intuitive explanation
how they work why they work and why it
matters and i just want to also
demonstrate how
in two core areas of our chatbot
technology uh we're actually making use
of this quite a bit
um so i hope that's going to be
interesting to some of you
um before i can go in depth in sort of
you know how this technology works let's
first discuss the problem that we have
at hand so at raza we like to provide
you with the technology to build your
own
uh digital assistant um so that could be
a chat bot can be
whatever you'd like but it means that we
have this conversation
uh with an end user and the conversation
could go something like
uh hello and then there's a sort of
digital assistant here that says hello
back then we have a user that says hey i
would like to buy a pizza
then there's this reply asking for what
kind of pizza
then the conversation could get
interrupted because a user could ask
by the way uh are you a human
and then we think it's ethical to never
pretend that we're human so it's really
important that we first reply
no i'm not a human i'm a i'm a bot but
then we would like the chatbot to
automatically pick up the conversation
where we left it
that's kind of the like one of the
scenarios that you might have
and there's actually quite a lot of
things happening in just just this short
conversation if you think about all the
moving parts and things that we'd like
to detect
so every time that a user speaks over
here
i could argue that's an intent every
utterance suggests that a user wants
something
and it's for us then to figure out what
to reply back
but it's not just that one such
utterance
is an intent i mean we could say that's
a classification
but it's also the case that inside of
the text there is a specific bit of
subtext that has a lot of meaning
so for the intent that we have over here
for example
the person wants to buy something and
what does the person want to buy
well a pizza but it could also be that
the person wanted to buy a burger
or a different type of product and we
really need to pick up this entity
in order to get the best reply here
so we have this interesting mapping from
intensive entities to actions that the
digital assistants should take and note
that i've drawn a couple of actions here
like the action of saying hello is an
action
but of course there's also an action
happening right after here because
the chat bot also has to recognize when
they should listen
and when they should speak so listening
is also an action that we have to detect
and this is basically one of the core
problems that we have we want to provide
you with
essentially lego bricks or building
blocks and to help you navigate this
sort of
problem so that means that we have
models essentially to
detect these intents we have models to
detect these entities
and we have models to detect these
actions and all these things by the way
are
super open source so you can check them
out but we are interested
in techniques that can do this
accurately
and not just in english by the way we
really want to have systems that work
well
also for other languages so
chinese zulu we really want our system
to be broadly applicable
now the interesting thing about the
problem that i've just
described to you is that both problems
they sort of have this
sequence if you think about it uh if i
see text appear in a sentence
then you could say ah it's kind of like
a sequence that's a first word a second
word
all the way up to a fifth and if we look
at the
dialogue that's happening then you can
also argue there's something of a
sequence happening here
we've got this text at time step one
we've got this text at time step two
that's a sequence over time
so the way that we're going to deal with
these um
with these text problems is going to be
somewhat related
to time series
and and here's why i'm going to try to
at least intuitively explain to you
what a transformer is and what it does
but in order to get there what i'm going
to do is just
make this one analogy
let's say that i've got this time series
this is something that's happening over
time
and what i could do is i could sort of
move this filter
over this time series now you can see as
the filter moves
uh at one point in time there's going to
be more attention
somewhere than somewhere else so right
now there'll be a lot of attention
my bad so if i look at the screen right
now
at this point in time you would get a
lot of attention on these points
and let's say at this point of time you
get a lot of attention around these
points
and this is a technique that you can use
to maybe denoise the original data it's
a filtering technique
and you can say well let's have a wide
attention span let's have like a thin
attention span but the idea is
that if this were a time series right
we're going to come back to text but
just one aspect of this is i start out
with this time series of dots
and then i have this i will argue this
attention mechanism
on how to smooth this out and you could
argue that this
thick red line that i have on top here
that's a more contextual representation
of the original data that i started with
there's less noise in my data by
applying this filter
and that might be more useful for
whatever task i have later
so this is filtering this pre-processing
step
that is something that can actually be
really really useful
the question is can we do something
that's really
similar to text because if we think back
of the original problem
the text sequences that we have in the
chatbot setting
those are also sequences
so let's let's sort of pick everything
apart of what's happening
in this current example we can say that
well let's say that there's this one dot
over
here and let's say that some dots that
i'll call x
i because we're at index i over here
but as far as that x i is concerned
we can say that this arc over here
describes where we are going to spend
our attention
and for as far as this point is
concerned we're not going to put any
effort into
points that are over here because those
are super far away we don't have to care
about any of that
so by understanding for this time series
how we should put our attention span
we allow ourselves the opportunity to
come up with this more contextualized
line
because it allows us to re-weigh the
original points
this filtering step is effectively
taking like a weighted mean
and all the points that are closer to
the point in question
those will get weighted more than points
that are further away
so it's like a a weighted mean that
we're doing here actually
and i would love to do this weighted
mean
but when i'm going to do it for text i
have to be really careful because maybe
i cannot do this
proximity argument here now
if you're a little bit familiar with
natural language processing techniques
you can imagine that we might have let's
say a token in a sentence here so i've
got bank
of the river and i've got this other
sequence of text
money on the bank
and we have these four tokens that
correspond to these
uh texts but you might remember that we
have these things
called word embeddings or vector
representations for words
and let's say that i'm interested in
sort of doing the re-weighing trick
based on the vector that i have over
here
well then i hope you might agree that in
order to get the most context for the
word bank over here
proximity is not going to cut it if i
were to think hey
this token bank what other word in the
sentence is giving it a lot of context
then it should be this one token over
here called river
that one word river is going to give me
a lot more information about this word
bank
and same here if i want to understand
what the word bank means here
then i would really like it if some of
the attention came from money instead
not the word the like the word that
might be more proximate but it's not
something that gives me extra meaning
so we're going to apply a mathematical
trick to go about this instead but i
hope that you
still have in your mind that yeah we're
trying to get this attention mechanism
to re-weigh all of these vectors that's
kind of the idea
now as luck would have it there's this
mathematical coincidence
let's say that this vector
and this vector let's say that they're
similar in some way
and you know if you have pre-trained
word embeddings you might just do the
dot product between the two
vectors and if that number is relatively
big then that's a
argument that you could say well they
might be more similar
in practice this this seems to hold um
and you can imagine that there's not
like if you look at the word vectors for
these stop words
since they don't have a lot of
information there's probably not going
to be a huge
overlap between the dot product of bank
and of
but there might actually be a lot of
overlap in
bank and river so that means that
instead of maybe using that proximity
that we use in a time series to say
where we should put our attention to
we might be able to do something with
the word embeddings that we start out
with already
so then you might get an attention
mechanism so to say that kind of looks
like this
and this is like a rough sketch of
course but let's say that i
do this dot product between v1 and v1 v1
and v2
3 4 then this might be
an okay sort of distribution of my
attention
for this token as far as bank is
concerned
sure the token bank is important but of
and the are not important and river
probably is important and the way that i
derive this
is because of this dot product with the
other word embeddings
and note that we have a very similar
thing over here the main difference
though is
is that here i'm looking to project
everything onto v1
and here i'm looking to project
everything onto v4 but
it's the same calculation by large it's
just that
um this is at the end of the sentence at
the beginning of the sentence
so if we have pretty proper word
embeddings right this can be an okay way
to do some re-weighing
but before we do the actual re-weighing
one thing that we should do
is we should remember that if we take
like if we take the height over here
and we add the height over here and we
add the height over here and we add the
height over here
then we might get a number that's not
exactly equal to one and if you're gonna
do some re-weighing i mean it's
kind of nice if you have like all your
weights sum up to one like a probability
a distribution
so what we'll do is we'll just do a
normalization step after this
and what we can then say is well we've
got these re-weighing weights now
because it's normalized these are the
weights that i could go ahead and use
for um for my attention
and the way that it would sort of work
and i apologize for the math symbols but
i'll explain what they mean
but the idea could be if i start out
with this
set of word embeddings then i'm going to
do all the dot products
then i'm going to normalize everything
so i have these weights
and then i can say okay this is the word
vector 1 that i start with
then i'm going to multiply this with
this
this with this this with this
and this with this and then add all of
that together
to get this more contextualized
word vector out effectively what these
weights mean
is how much should this vector
listen to itself its neighbor or maybe
all the way at the end of the sentence
so this is the
the nude re-weighed word vector that
should potentially have more context
it's like that denoising thing that we
did with the time series in the
beginning
and you can do the same thing for if you
do it for v1
you can also do it for v2 v3 or what
i've got here
v4 it's just re-weighing that we're
still doing
and if i were to make a comparison to
what we saw before
we have some sort of token at some point
in time that would be this
then we have some sort of an attention
mechanism
and we're using the dot product of word
embeddings over here but that gives us
this re-weighing factor
and by re-weighing all these different
points that we already have
then we have this contextualized word
embedding
that's this guy and i hope you
appreciate this analogy it's actually
like a
very similar filtering technique um
that we have in the time series domain
but now we just have this dot product as
the hack
to do something really similar in the
language domain and that is really nice
and convenient
again because in the time series you can
make this assumption that when things
are close to each other they should be
related
and you really cannot do that in
language bank
really needs to listen to river if you
want to understand what bank
means in this sentence
so on the right-hand side again we have
re-weighing based on time distance
but on the left-hand side we have
re-weighing based on embedding
similarities so to say
and yes to do this trick you will need
some sort of a word embedding that's
already pre-trained
but those are relatively common
so those are available in some in some
degree i would already argue
okay so we have bank of the river money
on the bank
and we have this system where we start
with some word embeddings
it goes through this i will argue
attention block and out comes a vector
that's more contextualized that's what
that star means
and i don't just have that for v1 by the
way i also have that for v2 v3
and v4 that can all just sort of go into
that block
this operation here would happen and
then what would come out is v1
star v2 star all the way up until v4
star
that's kind of the idea
and because we have that block that i
just drew maybe we can put this in a
neural network as well
we might have all of all the operations
that we just did defined as a layer
that'd be kind of nice
so i'm going to take one sip of water so
everyone can have a breather
but the idea is that the mathematical
operations that we've just described
we can actually rephrase that such that
we might have proper keras layers
you know that that's kind of interesting
because then you can do this with your
deep learning stack etc
so what i'm going to draw now is this
self-attention block and i'm going to
be a little bit diagrammy um but i'm
going to repeat all the steps that i did
just now
so on the left hand side i've got all of
these vectors that are coming in and on
the right-hand side
i've got all of my vectors um that are
more contextualized they'll be these
these vectors
now these vectors as they're coming in
it's kind of like an array of vectors
right
so that means that when i actually get
in here that's kind of more like a
matrix if you will
than a set of vectors
because a collection of vectors can also
be represented as a matrix
so that means it would also hold here on
the outside so you might argue hey
maybe they're not sets of tensors maybe
there it's like one giant tensor that's
two-dimensional
well okay then the first thing that
needs to happen is we
um we're first gonna do like a
mathematical multiplication right so
uh like we had before we had the v1
times v1 thing
and we had the the v1 times v2 thing
like all that stuff is happening here
after that we had this normalization
step so that we would have these
weights uh in between right so those
were the normalized weights
and then we would again do that
multiplication thing
down below because we would do something
like well let's do v1
pardon v1 times uh w uh
like i one plus v2
uh times w i
two and like you would do that for all
these vectors you would add that
together
and that's how you would get this
contextualized guy over here
and i'm not going to do the whole formal
math thing that's going to be a bit
boring for python talk but
i do hope that you appreciate that yeah
these are just matrix multiplications
and some normalization steps
and a matrix multiplication is
essentially a layer
inside of a deep learning framework so
we're in the green here as far as
implementation
possibilities goes
so that's kind of nice but if i now
start thinking about this right
um this system is pretty cool
right it's pretty cool we have this
attention mechanism that's already kind
of useful
but we should maybe think about the
properties of what we've got here
because this is not a
standard neural network layer
you'll notice that if i'm doing
multiplication here that's great
but i'm not learning anything yet
there's no weights in this
matrix multiplication if you think about
a dense layer in a neural network then
there are weights that you're going to
train there's a label somewhere you get
your gradient update
but currently there are no weights at
all in this entire system
so that means that the vectors that i'm
going to get out here
whoops so that means that the vectors
that i'm going to get out there
uh they're going to be really general
they're effectively
not trained toward a certain task and
that's you know i can imagine if you
have a label
like you're doing entity detection or
you're doing translation or you're doing
whatever with this neural network
but you still want to have this
attention mechanism be able to learn and
be able to specialize toward a certain
task
so roughly what you could do and i'm
definitely skipping a couple
of steps here because i want to keep it
on the intuition level
but one thing that you could do is you
can say well let's move some stuff
around inside of this
schema and let's just put a couple of
neural network layers there
now the idea is is that these can still
be regarded as matrix multiplications
but these matrix multiplications will be
multiplied with weights that we're going
to learn
the matrix multiplication that we had
here was a multiplication between
this matrix and itself
these layers will effectively say well
that's a multiplication between
these uh vectors and some other set of
weights that we're going to be
training that's the pattern that we're
gonna have to learn
and the idea essentially is if i get
some sort of gradient update
right so at some point all of this stuff
is going to be
connected to some sort of label right
and if i've got a label that means that
i have a gradient update that tells me
how well i've been doing
but because i now have those gradient
updates um
these are going to travel through this
system
and eventually they're going to update
these
layers so to say that that's kind of the
idea
and you can extend this idea as well but
but the idea mainly now is we've just
found a couple of places where we can
put these extra layers so we can also
specialize this attention mechanism
towards a certain task and i hope it's
plausible that if you're doing
uh neural translation then you want to
learn different things and if you're
just doing entity detection for example
so i hope that that makes sense
why we might want to have that and
there's like variants of this i should
say by the way
um so one thing that some people really
like to do is they like to add like
lots and lots of extra layers here in
parallel
what they would do is they would call
one of these layers ahead and by having
parallel a couple of them you get this
multi-headed attention what's
something that people like to call this
um but
to keep it simple for now though um
essentially what we're just still doing
is still
nothing more than a variant of the time
series task
the main thing to remember is that we
have word embeddings
coming in over here and they're getting
contextualized
and these word embeddings over here
might be able to focus on different
parts
and that's very useful again in the
example of bank of the river
money on the bank bank should mean
something different in both these
sentences
that's the idea
now to complete the whole story we're
almost sort of intuitively there at the
transformer but not not quite
but typically to wrap it up into like
what is a transformer
in the end the main component that sits
in the middle of a transformer the main
thing that made it
slightly different interesting and like
an extra step in the ecosystem
is that a tension block but what people
like to do is they like to put like an
extra dense layer at the end
maybe a sort of a dense layer in the
beginning in front of it
and all of those components together
that's what people like to call a
transformer layer
and there's again i should stress i'm
skipping over a couple of details and
there's many variants of this
but at least on an intuitive level this
is it
this is a transformer layer and again
the idea is that
we have we have text here
the text will be converted to word
embeddings that's a sequence
and then that sequences will be at some
point uh be passed to this transformer
and we have something here that's more
contextualized
eventually that'll be hooked up to a
label so we can start learning
and that means that this transformer is
able to update
any of the weights that are in here and
that's what a transformer does when it's
learning
so definitely glancing over a couple of
details but in the end intuitively we're
still doing the same thing
as with the time series now if there's
extra time i do have an appendix so we
can go a little bit more in depth
but what i kind of want to do now is
this was a theoretical part
this is the part where i was explaining
what a transformer sort of is and what
it sort of does
in the next bit what i hope to do is
show you
how we actually apply these because this
transformer layer is nice
but we've made some customizations to it
over at raza
um to make some models that we think are
pretty good at a lot of scenarios
for digital assistants and this is the
part where it gets exciting because uh
we've been able to add some nice
customization but
we've been able to customize this
transformer for our needs and i think
that's a night there's a nice lesson
there
so one thing that we like about this
transformer if you think about it and
there's a bit of a
a bit of a hand wavy argument but if i
if you were to say well this sounds
really familiar you wouldn't be wrong
because
r and n's these recurrent neural
networks they were doing something
that's really similar right
you could say that also for an rnn
there's word embeddings going in here
and there's word embeddings going out
so why would this be better than this
well the answer kind of is if i if i
didn't have any training data whatsoever
imagine a scenario i haven't seen any
training data yet then the node that i
have over here
is even without any training data going
to be slightly biased
to listen to this one and this one
it's you're going to need a whole lot of
data before
the note over here is going to start
listening to the note over here
that's a bit of a bummer there's already
a preference
for the sequence for the words that are
close to each other
even if it hasn't seen any data yet
and that's different with the
transformer if the transformer hasn't
seen any data whatsoever
then the attention is pretty much
uniform over the entire sentence
which if you're thinking about hey
what's a good starting point to learn
from
that's a lot better especially in our
scenario
where we don't have too much training
data typically
if you're starting out with a digital
assistant you're designing a chatbot
then it's probably going to be different
language than what people are
using on wikipedia so that means that
very often you start from scratch
and you're not going to have bajillions
of conversations that you can already
train on it's typically
maybe tens of conversations when you're
starting out so we like having a system
that's relatively robust
at being able to start in a lightweight
fashion and i hope that this hand-wavy
argument
it is hand wavy i agree but i hope that
you intuitively also appreciate here
hey that transformer is a little bit
more flexible in that scenario
and there's also more parallelization
options anyway um
theory i want to go to practice so
if we look at the original problem that
we had um there are two systems that we
have in raza that
uh use a transformer the first system
is a system that detects these intents
and entities
those are two tasks and we've built one
algorithm to handle both
and the other part of the system that we
have is a system that is able to
detect what the next best action is and
these two different systems use a
transformer in a different way
and i would like to show you how that
works
so intents and entities are found by the
system that we have called diet
now you can definitely also use psychic
learn if you have your own preference
for that that's perfectly fine
but the algorithm that we've designed
recently is called diet which stands for
dual intent and entity transformer the
idea is that we've built a system
that is able to handle both intents and
entities and because it's able to handle
both of them at the same time
we have reason to believe that it might
also be more accurate at
many tasks so the way it works
is i've got one utterance of a user on
the left hand side
and it's saying play ping pong that's
that's what the user is uh
sending my way now the way that we
encode that internally in raza is we say
well
uh you probably have some sparse
features like a count vectorizer just
count how often each word appears
and the thing is that we typically
generate these features
for every single word that we have
and what we also do is we try to have
one token that represents the entire
sentence
um so you could say well if this is a
one-hot
encoded thing i've got a one a zero zero
here
a zero a one and a zero zero one here
right so those could be the counts for
the words
and in that scenario i would have three
ones here
because i'm counting all three of the
words and a similar thing would happen
with the word embeddings as well
but the idea is this is the utterance
that i get this is what i sort of start
out with
then what we do is we pass that through
you know one or two feed forward layers
the main reason for that is
to make sure that we have a hyper
parameter for the size of what
comes out over here and then what we do
is we pass that into a transformer
and the thing that's interesting to note
here is we also pass this class token
into the transformer that's that's as if
it's another token it's something we
just throw in there
but it also means if we look at the same
argument we had before
that what i get here is essentially a
vector like what comes out over here but
more contextualized
and we have that over here as well over
here as well
and over here as well and in a minute
we're gonna
hear an argument why that might be super
powerful
because what we can do now is since
these words
are all separate words that could be an
entity
right and in this particular case you
could argue
well i want to play a video game that's
what the user is telling me
but what video game do i want to play
well it's ping pong
well what i can then do is i can sort of
say well i've got this entity layer over
here
and there's an entity that should be
detected there namely
the game i want to play there's an
entity over here namely what game do i
want to play
and you can imagine that there's this
nice little correspondence between the
token
i have over here and the entity label
over here
and there's a very similar thing
happening here so i've got this
separate layer for the intent and i've
got this intent
player video game over here but here
comes something that's actually quite
amazing
now let's think about the gradient
signal that i get sort of the feedback
if i'm actually
taking this system applying the gradient
descent on it and trying to learn
patterns from it
well then as an example let's say that i
get a gradient update from this intent
and note uh in production i'm also
definitely getting a gradient and
update from these over here but to keep
it simple let's assume there's a
gradient update
from this intent over here i'll be
updating this layer
but then we have this attention
mechanism happening here
and you could potentially argue that for
the intent
that you want to play a video game
you know this word play is going to be a
key part
of detecting that if a user types the
word play
in a commanding tense in the beginning
of the sentence you could plausibly
argue
i don't need to know the rest of the
sentence just that word play is already
telling me
what your intent might be so that might
also mean that the gradient
update signal that this layer is going
to receive and this layer is going to
receive
those are probably going to be more
fundamental and more strong
than the updates that i get over here
potentially because these
don't necessarily immediately
uh tell us anything about this intent
it might be that you want to play a game
or buy a game and the fact there's a
game in here
might certainly still give a boost but
you can imagine the nice thing about
this transformer
is it also routes the gradient update in
an appropriate way
now again hand-wavy argument definitely
aware of that
but to me at least it feels intuitive
that that is something that's going to
be extremely useful here
because this isn't just happening with
the intents it is also happening
with these entities and especially if a
certain intent
has certain entities that occur often
together and very infrequently without
each other
and that's a pattern that this system
can learn
instead of having two separate models
one for intents and one for entities
we think by having this transformer in
the middle we might actually be able to
handle both
and so far it seems that diet is working
quite well
and one of the nice things about diet
and that's something i do want to
mention
this system will work even if you don't
have any
word embeddings at your disposal and
this is really important to our users
because again english word embeddings
are frequently out there
but there are also some languages like
zulu where you don't have word
embeddings readily available
now i'm working on some open source
projects to make sure that we also have
word embeddings for those
but the nice thing about this system at
least is even if you don't have word
embeddings
either because no good ones exist for
your language or because they're
maybe super heavy the system will still
go ahead and work and do its best
there's still lots of features that can
be learned here
another thing that's kind of nice is
that if you want to go super heavy
say you're a big fan of the new bird
models out there then we can chug those
in here and that's kind of nice because
if you have a use case for it then you
can put the super heavy
word embeddings in there as well and
this is the nice thing about this model
and i think a transformer helps here
um this model can be used in different
ways according to whatever
you think is best for your application
and this customizability
that's a super nice feature so that's
both a feature of i would argue here our
diet system that we've built on top of
the transformer
but this gradient updating that's inside
of the transformer
uh that that's that's that's kind of a
nice milestone there's something really
cool happening inside of that
so this is the base model that we
provide inside of raza to handle
entities as well as intents and what i'm
going to conclude with now
is how we also handle actions but i hope
that already
the intuition has the mind boggling at
this phase
[Music]
the thing is we also have this thing
called ted it's a transformer
embedding dialog system and this is what
we use to handle
the actions to take now i'll go over
this relatively quickly
in the interest of time but if a user
were to say hey i'd like a pizza
well you know then we have a model
called diet that's going to give us an
intent
we have an entity that's detected we
have that from diet as well
we might also have some long-term
information filled in like the address
of the user might be something that we
know
and we also know the previous action
and you can argue well that's a feature
space that i have for an
utterance at a single point in time
it'd be nice if you can pass that to a
model and then that the model says oh
this is the best action you should take
but again we have a sequence here right
so that means
that we can have those feature spaces
over time
and then we can then say we'll chug that
into a model and have then
the actions here come out and then we
have a sequence over here
and i hope that you can imagine what
we're actually using here
inside of this model to facilitate this
that is another transformer but the main
thing that is
awesome about this the one thing that
struck me as sort of super interesting
is that you don't have to use word
embeddings in order to use
a transformer we're not even dealing
with text per se
these are just features that we know at
the moment and it's sparse data
but still we're able to use a
transformer in our experience so far
quite well in situations where a user
is maybe interrupting a chatbot and we
have to suddenly make the right decision
in the interest of time i'm going to
skip a couple of details about how this
transformer works
um it's a unidirectional transformer
because we're only allowed to look at
the future so there's a couple of
interesting details there
but in the interest of time i just want
to do one quick demo because then we'll
still have a little bit of time for
questions
what i have here is the rasa
configuration file
and what i also have is some training
data where the task is that the chatbot
is supposed to count down it needs to
start from 10 and then has to count down
and what i'm also doing is i'm asking it
not just the countdown but also if i
interrupt it by asking if it's a chat
chatbot
that is able to recover so
if this is my input and i say hey start
counting it starts counting at 10
and then i say okay but then it starts
counting at five and then i say okay
again
it's messing up over here but the reason
why it's messing up is because in this
configuration
for this particular tet policy i'm
saying that it's only allowed to look
one time step back
which is not going to be enough
information for the transformer to
actually learn a nice pattern
it gets a whole lot better if i say hey
your max history is actually supposed to
be three now you're allowed to look back
three times steps and then you notice
that it's actually
not the worst you know it responds okay
now it can count down
uh when it says hey are you a bot uh
then it's able to say no
i am a bot not a human and starts
counting down again
but it's not able to generalize there's
this moment that's not in the training
data
and it's it's it's not able to look
uh further back enough to actually
achieve the right context here
however if i were to put the max history
at 10 then we
see that even if i try to interrupt it
at instances that aren't in the training
data
it is able to recover it is able to keep
counting down
and it's able to still at every instance
reply that it's not a human which is a
feature that we like
and the reason why i think this is a
nice result is because when we tried
doing this
not with the transformer but with the
lstm type model
we noticed that the lstm actually has a
whole lot of trouble
you need to give it way more data so far
in this benchmark
in order for it to learn that you're
still supposed to count down
after saying that you are a chatbot
and not a human
anyway there's only like a couple of
minutes of time so um
very quickly the one thing i do want to
remind everyone of super fancy machine
learning that's great
but if you're building your own chat bot
definitely uh
label your own data and learn how users
are interacting with your chat bot
if this was interesting know that i have
like i'm paid to do this
on the raza channel on youtube i have
lots of videos that go more in depth in
material that i've discussed today
so if you're interested in this there's
the algorithm whiteboard on youtube that
you can definitely go and check out
and finally one thing i would also like
to mention is uh
on behalf of raza i uh i've open sourced
and maintained this project called what
lies
which is an interactive visualization
tool for many common uh word embeddings
and some of the features that i'm
currently implementing are features for
detecting bias in word embedding so if
that's interesting
reach out to me because these are
features that i'm building i'm going on
holiday next week but the week after
i'll be uh
implementing some things that help you
detect bias and word embeddings
anyway a little bit of rush at the end
but i hope people found this interesting
um and
now would be a good time to go ahead and
ask me some questions
uh i have already noticed that some
people are asking hey what am i using
uh gear wise because people seem to like
this pen
i've got a wacom one tablet and there's
an app for mac called screen brush
and every time i click alt tab i'm able
to just doodle
you can also do this with your mouse the
app is called screen brush
come to the chat room on discord and
i'll show you a link and a tutorial
and i'm using a yeti microphone uh it
was 140 bucks before corona started
so we have also a bunch of questions on
chat
sure uh well which one should i take
uh all right uh little
i will ask you sure yeah go ahead are
there moving graphs which you made uh
are they using matplotlib
oh uh yes they are so there's uh i go to
the discord i'll send you the link
there's actually a cool project called
gif and it's basically a decorator that
you put around a function that has
renders matplotlib
and gif is just the easiest way ever to
get pretty gifts from matplotlib
uh go to the discord channel after i'll
share the link
but yes it's method based okay the next
one
really interesting explanation of the
diet
uh in the net what do you have available
to qa a predicted label or to explain to
a user the label
oh that's super tricky in essence
because there is a transformer in the
middle
and every sort of like you can have
multiple transformers in sequence
so what you can do that's what what lies
does
is we can visualize the vectors going
into the transformer
and typically if there's like clusters
there that's something that can help you
inform
um but what raza also does is it gives
you this overview of common mistakes
that happen often
and what we mainly try to do is tell you
hey these two intents are often confused
with each other
and then you can investigate from there
that's that's typically the approach
that we offer
okay so this is a question from
francesco you said
that rnns perform worse because they are
intrinsically biased in assuming words
that occur
closer tend to be more related however
isn't this
assumption in most cases more correct
than assuming
as a transformer does that a word in a
sentence has equal chances of being
related to any word in
the other parts of the sentence well so
that's why i mentioned it's a hand-wavy
argument right so it's not necessarily
uh
100 solid and perfect and it definitely
depends on the use case
for our use case though you have to
imagine uh when you get started with a
digital assistant like your first demo
that's going to be based on 20 really
really short sentences
so at least for us right for our
specific use case
that one assumption holds just a bit
more you are definitely correct if you
say something like okay but now let's do
this for an entire document
and the document's like 20 pages i mean
you're sure then situation's different
and then
you cannot make this argument anymore
but at least so far in our results it
seems to be confirmed that's the main
thing i'd like to say about that
all right so so this question
asks you how does this compare to gpt2
or the recent gpt3 oh okay so
um i wrote a blog post on that uh which
i'm gonna be spell correcting in like
five minutes
um the main thing with g2b3 and uh i
hope people take this serious
don't underestimate what sort of bigotry
that thing can generate
if you give it sentences like uh the man
is known for
and the woman is known for or the person
with black skin is known for
you will see that it generates all sorts
of stereotypes
and yes i mean uh it's great that we
have the system that can generate text
but that's not the use case that our
users at least have
our users would like to build a digital
assistant that is reliable and
predictable
and that you can order a pizza and do
that kind of thing
we are currently investigating gpd3
maybe as a way to have a human in the
loop and generate
more expressive training data i mean
that can be a use case
but in general i think it is a really
bad idea to have something like gpd3
uh generate text as if it's a chatbot
like that's
i have trouble coming up with a good use
case for that especially in enterprise
okay thank you thank you very much for
your talk and i think
this is for you sure
uh happy people liked it uh and if
there's any questions i'll be on discord
for like another
20 minutes to like send links stuff and
uh
and i hope people learn something today
yes thank you very much